well actually that a everything fair
reason in my life I don't know what I
don't know about anyone else's life but
in my life everything for a reason and
even bad things is for a reason that who
knows it my turn would be something else
but you know I don't fight creativity I
don't fight against not being creative
if I'm not being creative I'm not
forcing it I just that's it I'm I'm
chilling you know I'm saying what
inspire me yeah I want to say is God
yeah but I want to put it out different
we all say it's the universe you know
it's this thing that we don't know what
it's called some people call it God and
people have different names for it I
don't know what it call it whatever you
want to call it I don't know sometime I
just said the universe that's what I
call it at times and that's what
inspires me you know the universe so
that's it you know I mean my kids as I
said before buck in the deers I maybe
ever know and again there is some social
thing that would spark a son you know
maybe a song about justice or a song
about human rights or every now and
again there's something happening in the
world where I write a song inspired by
what something but a lot of times now
I'm writing songs that that that have to
do it long enough for do it establish in
our reestablishing our connection to the
universe was our our spirituality
you know we reconnect in our
consciousness to universe it has nothing
to do with physical things our social
things our political things it's all to
do with spiritual things and that's
where I find that's where I love to
write songs the most in that place not
in the political social thing I like to
write songs in that spiritual place
that's that's what that give me the best
feeling you know
the best advice I ever received there's
been a few but I must say today the best
advice I have received is one that I
would say I receive from myself because
it's based upon my experiences and the
best advice I received from myself is
follow your intuition follow your mind
because I mean many times I have not and
I've seen where I should have so I and
you know each individual to each his own
it's not sometimes not everybody the
intuition is one thing but where I am
today in my life my intuition I should
follow it and that is that is the advice
I get from that inner voice inside of me
you know that speaks there's a voice
inside of me that speaks the truth and I
must always listen to that voice if I
did I wouldn't get money wouldn't be in
general that's the lesson that's the
lesson Ziggy listen to that's that's the
lesson that's a long time where I
learned something you know